all right so when i heard there was
gonna be a rainbow six siege spin-off
project i was initially pretty excited
and once i heard about all the
development problems the game was having
my expectations plummeted to basically
nothing but it came out on game pass i
figured what the hell we'll give it a
shot and weirdly it is one of the most
unique games i've played in a long time
it's a fresh but somewhat flawed look at
what makes siege so interesting in the
first place
let's chat about it
we're experimenting with doing some
shorter dome apnes for topics that don't
need the whole rundown you know so this
is one of those videos and if you like
it maybe like the video maybe even leave
a comment about what you like about the
shorter format and what you don't let's
get it so rainbow six extraction is a
three player co-op fps developed by
ubisoft montreal and you can play with
up to three players it puts operators
from siege in the role of a first
response team trying to deal with an
outbreak of an alien parasite it is the
parasite from rainbow six siege's 2018
outbreak event but things have changed
quite a bit since that time and the
story is now going in a different
direction so what is the game extraction
really well at its heart it's a stealth
oriented game players load into a map
with three distinct sections each having
a unique objective and throughout that
map the alien menace called the arkians
or archies for short act as the
antagonist to be avoided or dispatched
now if one of these things sees you and
it has enough time it shrieks and starts
calling in all its friends but the worst
part is that any nearby nests that get
riled up by this start producing an
endless stream of enemies until they're
destroyed yeah you can't just turtle up
and the objectives in this game
sometimes require stealth like the
biopsy objective that asks the players
to take down
multiple specific enemies with stealth
takedowns others are inherently loud but
either way the odds are stacked against
the players because you can't actually
regain health in this game you can boost
your health temporarily but if you lose
health it's gone until the end of the
mission and things hurt
the edge that the players need to win
are the operator gadgets and pieces of
tech that you unlock as you progress
through the game and because you can see
the objectives before you actually load
in you can tailor your team to those
objectives need to stealthily take out
some targets consider bringing vigil
need to defend some bombs from waves of
aliens
you know the lord's lmg might help out a
bit and many of their abilities have
been tailored for this game specifically
like pulse's heartbeat monitor that can
detect nests and its range is
substantially longer pinging everything
for your entire team
obviously we can't put that in siege and
like siege intel is everything if you
have enough of it then siege's vaunted
bullet penetration and environment
destructibility let you do all sorts of
things to deal with the alien menace
like assess the situation before running
in getting a stealthy takedown or maybe
just getting a cheeky wall you know
siege stuff if you die and your body is
left behind and captured your operator
is mia and unavailable for play until
you rescue them as an objective in that
area in a future mission so that's the
game in a nutshell a three-player
stealth focused co-op fps that takes the
great things about siege and applies
them to a whole other genre of shooter i
really love the way that siege's
operators and gadgets were incorporated
into the game and i like that they were
tailored specifically for this new
different threat that they're facing i
do feel like it would be good to have a
wider variety of objectives more
generally and i'm not sure what the
long-term replayability will be although
they seemingly already have a plan for
future content in place it felt like
each difficulty level was a clear step
up from the previous one and even though
your operators do gain some passive
power when they level
it's not enough to carry you now while i
enjoyed the core gameplay of this game
it does struggle to shine a bit it has a
ton of seemingly reused assets from
siege and even though the game isn't
full price right now i think it should
have been even cheaper or there should
have just been more content
it's not really a problem at game pass
prices but it's important to be honest
about what's actually here in the game
right now also
the story is pretty threadbare and
that's a disappointment given that we
have so many fan favorite characters and
this was a great chance to develop them
contrast that with how riot games are
using their runeterra based games to
explore and develop league of legends
characters outside of summoner's rift
and honestly this game feels like a big
miss on that front alright so what do
you guys think have you tried it maybe
you're thinking about just picking up a
month of game pass to give it a shot let
me know in the comments below really
excited to hear what siege fans think
about this project that's probably the
closest to siege but also pretty
different we'll catch you next time
i want to just rock the stash just the
stash bro
aviators
you better [ __ ] watch it josh
okay wow holy [ __ ] holy everybody dude
stop punching stop punching i'm punching
things